foreign
on this Thursday night hurricane Ian's
path of Destruction across Florida my
chimney came down I was afraid it was
going to come through the roof and crush
me the survivors the rescues the mammoth
cleanup as Ian returns to Hurricane
strength and heads to a new Target the
danger is real
the new normal for some newfoundlanders
I don't know what the normal might look
like devastated residents try to figure
out their next move mind the gap the
UK's new prime minister Under Fire as
the economy takes a huge tumble and
journey to recovery ten years ago I was
a totally different person the
inspirational indigenous dancer
harnessing the healing power of Powwow
global national with Donna Friesen
in some places there is
Fort Myers Florida the police chief says
there are no words to describe it
buildings are flattened boats piled on
top of each other pushed Inland by the
force of hurricane Ian rescue crews have
yet to reach some of the hardest hit
areas homes are gutted some completely
underwater how many people may have died
in Florida is still uncertain millions
are still without power and Ian is not
finished yet it has now regained
hurricane status
this could be the deadliest hurricane in
Florida's history
the numbers of still are still unclear
but we're hearing early reports of what
may be substantial loss of life
good evening and thanks for joining us
the storm surge is so massive it's not
known how many people might still be
trapped since hurricane Ian made
landfall on Wednesday as a category 4
storm its power engulfed all of Southern
Florida Jackson prosco is in Sarasota
Southwest Florida for us and he toured
parts of Venice earlier today Jackson
the pictures we're seeing just
heartbreaking what have you witnessed
well Donna everywhere you look there is
incredible damage from the blown out
windows of this skyscraper here in
downtown Sarasota to homes that have
been absolutely flattened and destroyed
up and down the coast one thing that's
quickly becoming clear tonight is that
this will be a storm for the history
books and it will likely take years for
Florida to recover
by light of day Ian's unprecedented
destruction came into view it is
unfathomable
as the storm made landfall category 4
Winds and a storm surge of up to four
meters pushed deep Inland trapping
people in low-lying homes
I was kind of scared for my children the
only bridge to Coastal Sanibel Island
collapsed leading no way for Rescuers to
get in or residents to get out officials
suggest there could be a large number of
fatalities there's no way to know how
many people are missing these people
were calling the water was Rising on
their home they may not have ended up
and ended up getting through uh so so
we're obviously hoping that that they
can be rescued at this point the scope
of This Disaster is remarkable almost
every home on every street up and down
the coast has suffered some sort of
damage and on top of that homeowners are
expecting to be without power for weeks
potentially months
volunteers are trying to clear roads for
First Responders that's where we met
Diana Dugan whose son ignored the order
to leave his home near Fort Myers still
trying to reach our son
so King County cell service what's it
like waiting to hear from your son right
now
I don't
need to focus on other
the damage stretches in every direction
and the full extent of Ian's destruction
won't be known for days
as the storm trudged across Florida it
caused severe Inland flooding deepening
the scars on this already battered state
because there is no cell service in so
much of the state there's a rush to
bring in as many as 100 portable cell
phone towers to help re-establish
Communications meanwhile there's major
concerns about insurance coverage in
this state most people do not have flood
insurance that would cover this type of
disaster and Donna several insurance
companies are said to be teetering on
the brink of insolvency especially with
the number of claims they're expecting
from this storm
so much work ahead Jackson prosco in
Sarasota Florida thanks well Ian is not
done this afternoon the storm regained
strength it is a hurricane again and
tonight people in South Carolina are
bracing for a direct hit Global News
chief meteorologist Anthony Farnell is
tracking it
Donna there are signs that's already
happening tonight the latest out of the
National Hurricane Center is that this
is once again moved from tropical storm
to Hurricane and there's room for this
to intensify further as it moves out
over the Gulf Stream the very warm
Waters just off the U.S southeast coast
and what we're seeing now some of these
brighter red and orange colors and then
the low level center right to the South
if that gets underneath these convective
Cloud tops that's when you could see
some intensification it will not be
rapid this is not going to be another
category 4 hurricane at landfall but it
may be a stronger category one and it
occurs over a very vulnerable section of
Coastline they call it the low country
in South Carolina right by the coast
because it's just barely above sea level
so we have another storm surge situation
that will be compounded by high pressure
to the north and that brings in even
more wind and water so we could see
anywhere from four to as much as seven
feet of storm surge in areas like
Charleston in South Carolina the
hurricane warning is now extended into
much of North Carolina as well and of
course there's the rainfall 100 to 150
millimeters that could cause additional
freshwater flooding thankfully after he
anticipates this weekend a much calmer
pattern in the tropics for the next
couple of weeks Donna Global News chief
meteorologist Anthony Farnell thanks
back in this country prime minister
Justin Trudeau was on Quebec's Magdalene
Islands today seeing firsthand the
damage from post-tropical Storm Fiona he
met residents there who need help to
rebuild promising to coordinate with the
province more than 700 Canadian troops
are now on the ground in Atlantic Canada
the defense minister Anita Anand met
with some of them working to clear roads
so power Crews can get in and people can
get moving again
in Newfoundland residents in Puerto
Basque are reflecting on what they've
lost and how their lives have changed
one woman was killed about a hundred
homes in the area were destroyed or
severely damaged by the powerful storm
surge as Ross Lord explains among the
biggest challenges is what to do next
Puerto bass Harbor has returned to its
enchanting appearance dominated by
rugged natural breakwaters and there's
incremental progress in the cleanup and
in the day-to-day life of residents who
still have homes taking the residents
and the electricians in to have a quick
assessment after electrical situation
their panels and see if it looks safe
enough to let those residents go back in
but the brutal remnants of Fiona's
overwhelming storm surge are still
everywhere as people who live on the
waterfront reconsider a word they used
to take for granted normal
um
The New Normal
I don't know what the normal might look
like the home where Kendra Savory grew
up is in limbo complete devastation
storm surge did not destroy the family
home but it Stripped Away part of the
exterior filling the basement with mud
leaving her parents with no working
sewer pipes I'm glad to see that they
got the U-Haul we can get moving because
if someone comes down to inspect the
place they might not be allowed to go
back in to get anything she says leaving
is especially tough on her father he got
a routine he goes on the wharf I can't
imagine that he can't
come back here and
pedal at his chores here so
I hope that he could
find Comfort somewhere else like he he
can with his own home since these
million dollar views became a tragic
nightmare most evacuees are staying with
friends or family members
help each other with everyday chores The
Province and the federal government
promised displaced residents who will be
settled by winter wherever their new
normal takes them
Ross Lord Porter Basque Newfoundland and
Labrador
in Nova Scotia Fiona's wrath dealt many
Cape Breton communities a devastating
blow trees are uprooted power lines down
and days after the storm made landfall a
number of migma communities are still
without power shalima Maharaj reports
among others is something Jeff Ward says
was ingrained in him from a young age
and that generosity runs in the family
my son who who's a culinary arts student
and worked at number two training
Convention Center for about 10 years 11
years cooking there it's actually a TA
here now so he's really good in the
kitchen so he was in there he's been
doing 12-hour shifts daily
number two First Nations elementary
school has been temporarily transformed
into a warming Center you get hot
showers you get warm food we have tea
coffee water there is a section of
member two that does not have power and
it's a small section and however they're
going on day six without power while
much of the community was remarkably
unscathed the warming center is open to
everyone in Cape Breton Regional
municipality it happens to others we
have that compassion and empathy for
others and we want to be there for them
now we're fortunate we never lost power
in my house so we give back
the work continues on this house its
roof damaged by the storm we're very
fortunate we do have Emergency
Management committees here in in member
two so we do do a lot of planning ahead
of time planning that appears to have
paid off health and safety director
Peter Stevens says overall 10 percent of
the community lost power you still have
no power in in bucking kick and pick do
which is hit very hard over there you
know that we've been our community and
the migamot community has been the
assistant these other communities
escason First Nation Chief Leroy Denney
says Chiefs across the province are
working together our priority is elders
and and for those who are disabled who
have oxygen tanks those are our
priorities we make sure generators go to
these areas
communities helping one another to clear
a path forward shalima Maharaj Global
News
things are not keeping calm in the UK
coming up the economic crisis and the
backlash over the new prime minister's
effort to tackle it
Russian President Vladimir Putin will
hold a signing ceremony tomorrow
proclaiming the annexation of four
regions of Ukraine moscow's Red Square
was closed today so a stage in giant
screens can be set up to celebrate the
annexation of 15 percent of Ukraine's
territory that and the Sham referendums
behind it are being called illegitimate
and illegal by Ukraine and by Western
leaders Canada's prime minister says the
results will never be recognized and
more sanctions against Russia are coming
I spoke with President zielinski of
Ukraine yesterday morning and reassured
him that not only is Canada standing
strong in its support of Ukraine and
it's pushed back against Russia's
illegal Invasion and actions but we're
also going to continue working with the
world to recognize uh that what Putin is
trying to do is completely illegitimate
Flint has closed its border to Russian
tourists shutting off their last
remaining direct land route to the
European Union the number of Russians
arriving at the border had surged after
the call-up of 300 000 military
reservists about 17 000 Russians crossed
into Finland on the weekend an increase
of 80 percent over the previous weekend
and Sweden has found a fourth gas leak
in the Nordstrom pipelines in the Baltic
Sea this video from the Swedish Coast
Guard shows huge a huge patch of bubbles
NATO says the incidents were a result of
deliberate Reckless and irresponsible
acts of sabotage the Kremlin dismisses
suggestions it is responsible saying
it's that is predictable and stupid
well a lot of people are watching the UK
right now the new prime minister just
three weeks into the job tried to
reassure voters today the economy is not
collapsing but that is not supported by
any evidence the pound has plummeted
mortgage rates are rising and the
central bank had to intervene to prevent
a run on Pension funds even the former
Governor of the bank of England Canadian
Mark Carney accuses Liz truss of
undercutting the nation's Economic
Institutions still she vows to stay the
course
it's a difficult time we're facing a
global economic crisis brought about by
Putin's war in Ukraine and what was
right is that Britain took decisive
action to help people get through what
is going to be a difficult winter
but Paul's out today show the public is
not buying it one gives the opposition
labor party a 33 percent lead over the
Tories and as Redmond Shannon reports
the prime minister's future is as
uncertain as the economy
Liz truss and the UK's Finance Minister
released their first interim budget
there was help for the little guy Brits
facing sky-high utility bills but there
was also a controversial tax cut for the
rich favoring the top one percent of
earners and we believe that high taxes
reduce incentives to work they deter
investment World Markets didn't buy it
the British pound plummeted to its
lowest level ever against the U.S
Greenback the bank of England quickly
said it wouldn't hesitate to raise
interest rates to protect the pound some
lenders then suspended mortgage offers
trust went AWOL unseen for days her
Finance Minister refused to comment do
you have anything to say about what's
going on sir
then on Wednesday the bank of England
intervened pledging to buy almost 100
billion dollars worth of government
bonds it was because their value was
falling and some pension schemes that
held them were reportedly at risk of
collapse the pound has recovered
somewhat and Trust broke her silence
recommitting to her plan despite calls
for a U-turn to reduce our tax burden to
make sure we grow the economy and also
curb inflation and that's so important
it's a difficult time even the
international monetary fund has gone
public with concerns about the move
toward trickle-down economics I think
the onus was on British policymakers to
be more cautious than normal when the
global environment was so turbulent
rather than to take what is really quite
a reckless gamble at the worst possible
time
just three weeks ago trust took over
from an embattled Boris Johnson now amid
dire poll numbers she is mired in a
crisis that remarkably already has her
on Shaky Ground Redmond Shannon Global
News London
we now know a little more about the
circumstances of the death of Queen
Elizabeth her death certificate has been
released and it lists the cause of death
as old age no contributing factors were
listed the time of death was 3 10 in the
afternoon that's about three hours
before the public was informed it's
believed her son King Charles and her
daughter Princess Anne made it to
Balmoral Castle in time today hundreds
of people lined up outside Windsor
Castle to see if the final resting place
of the queen which opened to the public
for the first time
the future of fertility ahead how
artificial intelligence might be able to
help some Canadians start a family
you're watching global national
anyone who has gone through fertility
treatment knows what a roller coaster it
can be from Hope to Despair and if
you're lucky Joy plus of course a huge
financial burden there have been lots of
advancements in fertility treatment
since the first IVF baby in 1978 but the
odds of it working are still not great
some Canadian scientists are working to
improve those odds using artificial
intelligence Sophie Louis looked into
this for the new reality Sophie
yeah wanting a baby and being able to
have one don't always coexist biology
doesn't work in everyone's favor sperm
doesn't really age not fair at all men's
sperm is unchanged and viable their
whole life but for women it's a
different story after the age of 35
women's chances of getting pregnant
decrease rapidly that's why women in
their 20s and 30s freeze their eggs as a
backup measure to increase the odds that
they will be able to start a family when
they're ready the challenge is the
quality of those eggs can't be assessed
by the human eye or even through a
microscope that's why fertility
specialist Dr Dan nayat is working on
artificial intelligence that could help
identify which eggs are most likely to
lead to successful pregnancies although
we've tried to visually score eggs for
decades now there hasn't been a
validated evaluation system We Believe
machine learning could unlock this
mystery his program uses thousands of
pictures of eggs and correlates them to
successful pregnancies in an effort to
predict which eggs are the best
candidates he's had interest from around
the world in his Ai and some clinics are
already putting it to use and he's not
the only Canadian working on helping
people with fertility issues we'll have
more on other ways doctors are
innovating to help people make babies
Donna all right thanks Sophie and you
can watch Sophie's full report on
Innovations infertility on the season
debut of the new reality that's on
Saturday at 7 right here on global
the power of Pow Wow next how indigenous
tradition helped one man overcome trauma
and illness
[Music]
powwows are a celebration of indigenous
culture and are open to anyone who wants
to witness the drumming and dancing it
wasn't always so they used to be banned
across the country now powwows are
making a comeback nithu garcha spoke to
one BC man a cancer survivor who found
the power of powwows helped him to heal
and help others
more people are starting to recognize me
and see that who I am his name is Peter
white but he goes by Peter not so white
there's a play on words with that that's
my last name is white and I'm not white
and he's also making a name for himself
as an inspirational indigenous dancer
before
after using social media to encourage
connection to indigenous culture and
raise awareness about the impacts of the
systemic oppression
that's how residential schools have
affected me so much so
um yeah 10 years ago I was a totally
different person the intergenerational
Survivor was adopted at birth to a
non-indigenous family struggling with
the disconnect in his teens he grappled
with alcohol abuse and homelessness
but now he packs what helped him heal
some of the very things those
institutions of assimilation tried to
erase I had a tumor on the top of my
right foot and that's when I decided I
need to start dancing I started going to
the local Palace just to for something
to do on the weekends to keep me sober
and while it was the cancer that got him
started it's the power of powwow that's
provided his path to recovery
you're able to Burma regalia in public
to have long hair to do these things
that's that weren't able to happen for
our ancestors
those ancestors became prisoners of the
Potlatch ban the law only lifted in
1951. until then it was a crime to
engage in cultural dance leaving many to
this day either unaware how to dance or
too traumatized to try then this is
going to be like kicking off the powwow
with the parade High School teacher Rick
Joe is working to change that by
organizing reconciliation focused events
anybody can come and attend and being in
the room and just being a witness to
that and experiencing that is going to
be for some people for their first time
that relationship was never there before
and the students wouldn't talk about it
at school they felt too it felt like a
risk to talk expose their themselves as
yeah I'm indigenous and yeah I I Pao
dance like it's a bad thing but it's
really it's a wonderful thing
Peter part of a large and grow
[Music]
and grunts again taking pride in these
sacred cultural practices
Global News Burnaby
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is this bear on the shore in
Tofino not an unusual sight there we'd
love to see your Canada please email it
to viewers at globalnational.com and
thanks for watching Fara Nasser will be
at the anchor desk tomorrow and I'll see
you Saturday on the new reality bye-bye
foreign
[Music]